hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the
fide 2021 candidates tournament uh we
are in round nine and this is dingle
iron versus maxim bashar lagrave and the
ding is not
doing great in the first half of the
tournament which was played in
the year 2020 being already lost three
games in the
losing three games out of the seven
games you've played in the first half of
the candidates tournament
is just terrible and unless a miracle
occurs
it doesn't really seem very likely that
you will be getting your chance in
challenging magnus for the title
uh but you know crazier things have
happened in chess so it's not
out of the question completely and the
ding already lost he lost the
maxim here he lost to van gaal and he
lost to
i think he lost to let me just check for
a really
uh quick uh moment
uh yeah he lost to van gaal to maximum
uh and tayani punish in the first half
of the tournament and now he gets his
chance
at revenge against maxime here so
without further ado let's check it out
it's quite a nice game adding with the
white pieces opens with
d4 uh we have knight to f6 c for
g6 and everyone knows that if you play
e4 maxine goes for the night or if you
play d4
uh maxim will at least try to go for the
kings indian defense or for his
groomfeld
uh if at all possible and uh here uh we
have h4
not allowing maxim to go for his
standard groomfield setup
and it is very sharp but i mean it's
2021 whoever
plays chess has to be ready for h4 at
any moment since uh the appearance of
alpha zero
uh h4 has been played in pretty much any
position
and this is no different and maximum
already faced this
in some very top tier games he played it
against uh
magnus carlsen in the 2019 saint louis
blitz tournament magnus defeated him in
that game
and he also played it against grishok in
the 2019 paris grand chester blitz event
uh where he also lost so here and ding
is banking on
so far uh whenever maxine faced h4 in
this position
he lost the game but those were blitz
games uh so let's see what maxim has in
store for a classical game with bishop
g7
knight to c3 and now against the
gerishuk he played d6 here so now he
strikes immediately in the center with
c5
same idea he used against magnus with d5
advancing in the center and now d6 here
e6 was uh attempted against magnus the
the game that we've mentioned but now d6
we have e4 and now uh e6 and it is
already as of move six that we have a
completely new game
so very exciting stuff we have bishop to
e2 now already putting a lot of pressure
after that h5 square h5 could be coming
at any moment
uh and e captures on d5 now we have e
captures
and now knight b to d7 so sort of a
benoni type structure here
uh we have knight to f3 uh kind of a
weird move everyone was expecting
h5 since all of your pieces are eyeing
that square but he just continues
development knight to f3
and here uh maxine could also continue
just the you know developing let's say
castles then let's say bishop f4 goes
after the pawn here
and now you either go queen to b6 or you
play knight to b6 or something to
to you know defend your pawn uh but here
instead maxim goes knight to g4
probably with the idea that uh this
knight can now come to f6 but he can
also
put a lot of pressure on the center now
maybe uh so
uh ding takes this opportunity to
advance the pawn to h5
right away uh queen to e7 a very nice uh
move
with the queen and now bishop to g5
and this is a very tricky idea because
here if you play f6 which is kind of
okay we all know you know don't play f6
ever like ever
but sometimes it works and here it
doesn't work because here the idea is
h6 and this is very nice uh with the
idea that if f
captures h captures and now we have to
uh move the
rook otherwise if queen captures the
knight captures and g5 is very strong so
rook to g8 and now we play queen to d2
again putting more pressure on g5 the h
seven point is also
uh vulnerable so here h6 would have to
be played now we're gonna castle
queenside
and now we really don't care we are uh
simply enjoying our position with white
the black king is still in the center of
the board and if something like knight
captures on f2
let's say going after the rooks just a
rook h to e1
and that's a lot of a lot of problems
knight captures on d1 for example you're
just gonna play bishop captures open up
this attack knight e5
uh and then knight captures d captures
and now d6 and it's uh really just a
terrible position for black white is
definitely winning this
uh all of the lines are now open the
knight can come to e4
uh it's just uh really really bad
uh so that being said after this uh
bishop to g5 move we have bishop
captures on c3 with
check first uh b captures and now
f6 so now it's a bit of a different
story because there's no uh bishop and
g7
and the no tempi can be gained uh so
here bishop to d2
retreating and now g5 uh we have castles
by ding and
now comes knight g to e5 so bringing
that knight in the center of the board
as he imagined we have knight to d4 now
and
here we've reached the position from the
thumbnail this is a very long game so i
think i'm going to be using this for the
thumbnail
because this is just so nice i mean
knight the d4 have
have my knight and the thing is no one
actually thought that he would accept
this because it's simply too dangerous
captures captures if the knight moves
rookie one i mean
who in their right mind would play this
but uh
maxine would that's right maximum never
takes the easy way out and as you've
seen in the previous round
uh maxim really doesn't mind uh you know
suffering for for the rest of the game
or maybe he thrives on this maybe he
doesn't even suffer who knows
but okay see captures he uh gladly
accepts this
we have c captures on d4 and now it
would be
uh maybe a bit dangerous to try and save
the piece let's say knight f7 then
bishop d3
rook rook maybe coming to e1 uh and then
castles
could be playable but it's a very very
dangerous position f4 is coming you're
gonna open up the f file for the rook
and
the bishop pair is fully operational it
would be
it would be interesting to say the least
however maxim says nope
i'm not going to keep the peace maxim
never hangs on to material he's just
that kind of a player
so castles uh and now ding wins back the
piece
d captures an e5 with f captures and now
bishop to e3 so what do you play here
queen to d2 is coming uh that this will
add additional
problems for this g5 pawn and you could
do you could do a lot of moves for
example but
uh it's very hard to find the move
because well
you can develop the bishop the knight is
uh you know
in the way if you play knight to f6 then
you're no longer defending the g5 pawn
if you play something like knight to c5
which seems very reasonable
uh just captures captures and d6 and
again you're in a
uh in a lot of pain here bishop can come
to f3 to d5 and it's just uh i mean
and of course there's a pass pawn on d6
already so instead after bishop to e3 we
have b6
now uh preparing to develop the light
square bishop uh
differently and also now we will be able
to play knight c5 because then we're
going to be able to recapture with this
pawn if bishop ever
captures on c5 so a4
uh and now comes knight to c5 as planned
with a5 by ding
and now rook to b8 they are getting
ready
to capture back with the with the a pawn
rook to a3
now uh guarding the entire third rank
and also helping out with uh well
maybe with the attack if you know the
position allows it maybe you can quickly
shift the rook over to the other side
we have h6 now not allowing any queen d2
bishop captures
action and queen to d2 nonetheless we
have bishop to f5
continuing development and now a
captures on b6 we have eight captures
and
rook after a1 so after all is said and
done ding won the a file
and of course rook to a7 could be coming
so rook to b7
and queen to d1 now so what can what can
black do here
king g7 maxim starts improving the
position of his king
and now rook one to a2 we have knight to
e4
uh and here comes bishop to d3 and this
knight to e4 is a very
uh very paralyzing move from black's
perspective because now after bishop to
d3
the knight can't really go anywhere if
you if you just move it back for example
you run into the very nasty bishop
captures
rook captures and queen b1 now just
attacking the rook here
also the rook can't really go anywhere
because then queen g6 checks so you have
to play this exact move with the rook
and then we're gonna play rook b2 go
after the pawn and after the queen
defends it
now we're going to play rook to a8 and
all of black's pieces are tied down
white's position is just very very
enjoyable
so instead after this bishop to d3 move
maxine played
queen to f7 and the situation on the
clock here if anyone's interested is 40
minutes for ding and 53 minutes for
maxine
so it's not like ding is you know just
playing out his preparation completely
he's actually you know
grinding this game out so queen to f7
and now rook to b2 now ding will switch
the rooks over to the b file to put
pressure on b6 the bishop and rook
already attacking it
and here uh we have knight to c5 and
this is a very interesting idea
not maybe not the most precise one but
it's
it's such a position that it's
incredibly difficult to find the most
precise idea
so probably bishop to h7 is the most
precise but who
who in the right mind plays such a move
and then if rook a6
adding more pressure here then we play
knight to c5
and then after for example everything
gets traded off captures captures
captures and captures
now we play queen to e2 and uh we uh you
know retain
all this pressure on the position we
have to keep an eye on the f2 point we
can play queen to e4 we can push the d
pawn there's pressure on the b6 pawn
and it's uh it's a very strong game but
maybe maybe black can hold however here
maxine played knight to c5 and now ding
uh definitely has uh well a very
interesting move here and it's not
uh it's not the same what do you do here
so just for fun we didn't have
all that many positive video moments so
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for white here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on capturing
something
but it's not uh you know just uh capture
anything here you have to play uh bishop
captures on f5
problem is if you start with bishop
captures on c5 and i know you guys were
thinking between the two uh the problem
is then we played b
captures on c5 open up and attack
towards the rook
and after rook captures queen captures
now we don't really gain anything
if bishop captures just rook captures
and black's position is perfectly fine
however if we reverse the move order or
if we remove
reverse the capture order we play bishop
captures on f5 first
then black's response is forced queen
captures on f5
now we play this so this is impossible
because the rook would now hang
so d captures on c5 and now we get to
the position where
uh well it has been discussed quite a
lot so feel free to pause the video
now for real and find the winning move
for ding
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on playing
uh the well i i believe to be the only
move that wins and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's uh not there rook to f3
this is just uh just a really really
strong idea
problem is uh black's position is just
bad
uh one thing is uh i think magnus
mentioned in the video that after queen
to e4 it seems that black is fine but
then they realize that it's
maybe not the case problem is that you
can just trade the rooks captures
captures and then go for this queen to
a1 maneuver now the problem is queen to
a8
check wins the rook and after you get
away from check you still play queen to
a6 now the rook has to move you're gonna
win the b6 spawn
uh of course if uh rook keeps an eye on
the pawn then we just attack it with
check and win the rook
uh so you'd have to go somewhere else
let's say rook to e7 and then of course
comes queen captures on b6 and now this
position
is uh well very much in white's favor it
would be hard to imagine that
ding will not win this game he's up a
pawn he has a pass pawn this
pawn is very soon to fall so this
would definitely be possible uh but this
is not even the best after rook to f3
not queen to e4 queen to d7 holds the
best
uh but we still trade captures captures
and then we play queen to b1
now we have pressure on b6 we have
access to the b6
square and uh if black wants to hold
this he's going to have to play
queen d6 now guard the both of these
squares but still uh
it's very very uh difficult to hold this
for white
while you have for black it you have a
lot of options here you can go rook here
rook to a6 rook to a8 you have queen f5
you can
go well okay you can't go there for a
moment the rook is guarding it
uh but uh it's basically only white can
play this and only white can uh
win this eventually so rook to f3
definitely
the absolute best here uh however ding
goes for a different idea he plays queen
to e2
adds another defender to the f2 pawn and
now this
kind of slows up his uh his uh gameplay
because it doesn't seem like black has
all that much to do
but if you give maxime at least one idea
he will find it and he will play it so
here he starts with e4
and now you will see that it's not so
easy because there is no more rook to f3
anymore
so what do you do we have broke the e3
putting pressure on this pawn
now rook e8 uh maxime defense we have
rook to b5 now by ding
a nice paralyzing move but uh nothing is
really being forced
so queen to e5 we have g3 uh giving the
room uh
for the king to breed a little bit and
now queen to d4
uh and here we have rook back to b1 uh
so what do you play here the situation
on the clock is 14 minutes for ding so
he spent quite a lot of time deciding on
what to play
against 40 minutes for maxine but we are
five moves away from reaching time
control so you know
not really that big of a deal and here
we have rook
rook to f7 an interesting attempt was b5
definitely but then we get something
like rook characters through a capture c
captures and after queen captures on d5
it still would be
a much better position for white
so of course he doesn't go for that but
it was an interesting idea so after rook
to f7 we have rook to d1
pushing the queen back maybe getting
ready to start pushing the pass pawn
queen back to f6 and now we have the
immediate
d6 and this immediate d6 might
not be the absolute most correct way to
go maybe you
uh improve the position a little bit
first but the ding decided that it's
definitely time to push this
and uh let's see what happens now we
have rook to e6 preparing to win the
pawn
d7 now advancing the pawn all the way
preparing
to queen the pawn and now rook to d6 and
now uh
of course you you you cannot push any
further so you have to trade
we rook captures queen captures and now
rook captures on e4 so this is what
being achieved here uh it's not much but
they have both
reached time control so move 40 has been
reached after rook captures on d7 and
both are now awarded with additional
time
so let's see how the game continues we
have king to g2 by ding
queen to c6 now happening the rook of
course now the
uh rook cannot move we have king to h2
queen back to f6 maxine saying okay
i really uh don't think i have much to
not much to play for here i'm very happy
with the draw
so king h3 queen to f5 with check we
have g4
and now queen to f6 we rook the e5
and now queen to d6 and now king back to
g2
queen to c6 check and now comes f3 and
this is
something that's referred to uh as i've
learned today as the alpha zero defense
the point is you will bring your king
over to h3 and the black will need at
least
two moves to deliver check so white will
use this time to
uh will create some counter play and uh
you know try try and trick black into
uh falling for some sort of a trap but
it is uh you know
in the old days you know uh pushing this
pawn to f3 and g4 would be
uh frowned upon to say the least because
then you just allow checks not only
along the first rank but along the
second rank as well but
these are modern times and you know
modern moves and ideas are required so
here
uh f3 we have queen back to d6 not with
ideas
maybe trading queens so queen to e4 and
now basically setting a trap for black
because if you are persistent in
checking the white kingdom king h3
and now you're lost uh because how do
you defend queen g6 is coming if you go
back and then we just play rook to e6
and that's it
queen f8 we're going to go for example
queen g6 checking h8 and now we're gonna
win the black queen
so after queen e4 we have brooke the a7
now trying to deliver some
uh checks along the second rank as
dingle audit and
king h3 this is the point now black will
need at least two moves to deliver a
check
so rook uh sorry a rook to f7 check now
again putting pressure on the f3 pawn so
you don't have all that many moves uh
and now comes uh uh rook
rook the e8 the idea is of course if
rook to e6 then we just capture on f3
with
check that's the idea and then after
queen captures we have a clear
shot at that rook on e6 and then we
retain an extra pawn
so rook to e8 and now comes queen to f6
uh another another interesting attempt
now just going for the
for the f3 pawn and white doesn't really
have any ways
of uh dealing with this he just has to
bring the king back
king to g2 now queen to b2 with check
king h3 we have queen back to f6 again
maxine happy with the draw here king g2
we have queen tabitoo with
czech king g3 and now queen to f6 uh
king g2 we have queen to b2 with
check king g3 queen to f6 and now queen
to d3 being not ready to call it a day
uh he will try uh some other ideas as
well so queen f4
check king g2 you have to keep an eye on
the pawn uh
queen back to f6 king g3 queen of
fortuna king g2 queen f6
and now queen to e2 again trying to
trying to trick mcsteam somehow rook to
d7 and
now comes queen to e4 again if you try
rook to e6 now
uh we you run into rook to d2 so there
there are always ideas like this that
simply don't allow white
to play for any advantage and now yeah
of course if you capture rook captures
on f6
rogue captures an e2 with check king f1
attacks the rook now we're going to play
rook c1
rook captures on b6 and now rook
captures on c4 and again the material is
equal yes black does have a pass pawn
but it's not gonna be worth all that
much what just puts a rook behind the
pass pawn
and that's it and you constantly have to
worry about this weakness so
not much to look at so after rook to d7
we have queen to e4
and now comes rook to d2 check king h3
and now queen to d6 threatening
checkmate with both
the uh rook and the queen so rook the e5
blocking checkmate and
now king f6 putting pressure on the rook
here
so rook f5 check king g7 rogue back to
e5 with king f6 and now
uh we have a repetition uh rook f5 check
king g7
and now queen to b7 check ding has to uh
you know deplete every option possible
before he calls it a day
so queen b7 check king h8 queen to a8
with
check king g7 queen a7 with check king
h8 and now even queen to a1 with check
uh you have to this is a very important
principle in chess
even though you know it doesn't work and
sometimes you may be unsure of whether
it works or not
uh give your opponent as many
opportunities to make a mistake uh
before you know switching to something
else because history has shown that
even though you know the positions may
be drawn maybe you know completely
you know uh worn out uh uh or already
analyzed positions but
uh humans uh make mistakes so here of
course if you move the king to a weird
square then you allow rook f7 check and
then it's just game over
king g8 quinta g7 will be checkmate
so of course uh king to g8 was played
and the now comes queen back to a8 with
check king g7 queen to a1 with check
king to g8
and now rook back to e5 uh blocking
against
checkmate so it's easy to you know miss
things like uh
these when you're playing and sometimes
you're like okay let me try another idea
and then you forget
you know you're you're the one getting
checkmated so here
queen back to f8 going after the f3 pawn
and
queen to a3 now defending and now again
you have to be very careful if you get
greedy go queen f4 or something
uh you get queen eight check and now
you're either getting checkmated or if
something like
let's say queen to f8 then you just
nicely win a queen and then checkmate
the black king
so after queen a3 uh we have rook to f2
now with
uh more pressure on the f2 pawn and now
king g3
defending we have queen therefore with
check now uh
forking the king and the rook uh
captures captures and now we have a
queen's end game which as you know are
the most complicated end games in the
entire chess
uh so queen eight check king f7 and now
queen to b7 check a very interesting end
game
occurs after queen to d5 check so we
will briefly cover it uh
point is that after queen captures and
pawn captures
it seems that uh both white has some
good
moves but black also has this very
outside past
b pawn point is that after b5 white has
f4 and now you cannot go g captures
because then white just sacrifices the
other pawn as well
and then the h1 is very strong for
example b for h7
you have to guard against this pawn then
d6 and if b3
you're gonna play d7 uh b2 and then
you're gonna bring a queen into the game
yes black does that also better than h8
queen and as you know
uh two queens are better than one uh so
while this doesn't work after f4 of
course black doesn't capture black just
continues pushing on the queen side
and then uh we continue captures on g5
we're gonna continue pushing
g6 with check yes white also has a pass
pawn now
but it doesn't matter king e8 we're
going to play d6 b2 now and now
g7 you're going to block that pawn now
d7
and b1 queen and now uh doesn't really
matter
what you do pretty much captures
captures and d8 queen it's a it's a
drawn end game there's not much there
not much to be done here a queen each
and two pawns each
so after king to f7 it is very
interesting but it
doesn't really do anything so queen b7
check we have king to f8 and now
queen to c8 with check another
interesting uh
end game is maybe queen capture some b6
but maybe not so much
uh because uh here you just continue
checking the the kink
queen h2 queen h1 queen h2 queen h1 uh
problem is if you go after this pawn
then this is just bad
if you capture it this pawn is hanging
so that's the problem it hangs with
check then this pawn falls and then
white is winning
uh but okay after king f8 we have queen
c8 with check
king to e7 and now queen back to b7 with
check king of f8 and now queen captures
on b6
uh but now ding has to check his last
option whether or not
maxine will go for this but maxine is
pretty much
the the most resilient player so he of
course goes for queen to h2
check king f1 and now queen h1 check
king e2 we're gonna play king the g2
check
now king e3 we do not want to lose this
pawn so queen g1 check king e2 queen g2
king e3
queen g1 king to e2 and it was in this
position on move 88
that dingle iron and uh maxima sherlock
resign agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here but also
it's a three-fold repetition i believe
uh so yeah a really really uh really
tough
game and i really thought ding would
bounce back in this one
since he had a terrible first half of
the candidates tournament and mexi maybe
after losing uh
the game yesterday but you can see how
quickly maxine bounces back he
again went into this position where he
kind of
i i don't think he's even suffering i
mean to us it appears that he's
suffering but i think he just thrives in
positions like these
uh where you know he uh invites people
to attack him to attack him to attack
him and then you know you're like uh
you know some some vicious creature you
know jumps out of the bush and you know
bites your leg off
uh but yeah really really awesome stuff
and
this was the moment where ding could
have seized the initiative
i believe after this d captures on c5
move he should have gone for a rook to
f3
uh but for some reason he he gave one
one tempo
to maxime and then maxim just you know
strike with e4 took away the f3 square
it's an easy move to miss this e4 idea
uh but you know uh i i
i guess uh anything can happen
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh in case we
don't show any more games i will try i i
don't know how
how much uh uh i will be able to uh so
let's just check the standings before we
uh head off to
uh around 10. so still in first place
yanni ponishi
uh in second place fabiano karwana
maksim bashola grav and anish giri
shared uh with fifth point with four
points kirila aksenko
uh wang khao and alexander grieschuk and
in the last place still
ding lyran with without a single win
which is simply incredible
uh but yeah uh it's just anything can
happen and or
anything will happen uh so once again
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank
mr hoody guy uh roberto smith pablo
mohan patrick solarz and frank phil
oscarson for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day